bonsoir nous sommes jeudi 24 septembre
merci de nous retrouver pour cette
nouvelle édition de votre journal local
a tout de suite on commence avec le
sommaire de notre actualité un des
moments les plus importants pour la
communauté musulmane la fête de l'aïd el
kébir c'est aujourd'hui les fidèles se
sont retrouvés lors des prières très tôt
ce matin avant de se rendre à l'abattoir
pour récupérer leurs moutons réduire le
déficit de la sécurité sociale
l'objectif de la ministre de la santé
marisol touraine seulement le seulement
l'appelant présente aujourd'hui inquiète
les pharmaciens ces derniers attendent
que les économies se fasse ailleurs que
sur les médicaments est encore enfin le
point sur la nouvelle saison du club de
basket du trapel débuté samedi en
nationale 3 et en plateau avec nous
patrick bernheim bonsoir à vous et merci
d'être venu vous nous parlerait dans
quelques instants de l'économie
circulaire et collaborative dans les
yvelines nous y reviendrons mais avant
cela passons en revue l'actualité hier à
bruxelles un accord européen sur la
répartition des 120 mille réfugiés
syriens et irakiens a été signé en
france ce sont 33 mille personnes qui
devraient être prises en charge sur les
deux prochaines années dans les yvelines
certaines communes comme bonnes elles
ont déjà accueilli et d'autres se
préparent à l'arrivée des prochains
réfugiés on écoute le maire de
versailles françois de mazières
c'est le taux était administrative donc
en l'occurrence on va dire
le ministère de l'intérieur qui a
souhaité qu'il y ait un site qui
permettent de recueillir des réfugiés
qui ensuite repartir et dans d'autres
villes de france
c'est totalement géré par les temps est
absolument pas par la ville aujourd'hui
il n'y a toujours pas de personnes
accueillies
peut-être qu'il n'y aura pas compte tenu
des difficultés que l'on sait puisque
aujourd'hui les réfugiés cette
autorisation d'allemagne egea à nouveau
en grève ce matin les salariés du site
de montigny le bretonneux se sont
mobilisés contre le plan de
restructuration de l'entreprise
les syndicats ont organisé une journée
d'action intersites rassemblant les
trois autres sites français
saint-apollinaire nantes et château
thierry cette société allemande
spécialisée dans la conception et la
fabrication d'équipements industriels
emploie 9 160 salariés en france
104 emplois à temps plein seraient
menacés une partie des postes supprimés
pourrait être délocalisé aux philippines
et en roumanie
écoutez le socialiste guillaume balas
député européen il s'est rendu sur le
site de montigny le bretonneux ce matin
afin d'afficher son soutien aux salariés
on est face à une situation incroyable
puisque l'entreprise g a fait des
bénéfices absolument considérable a
aucun problème financier
et ben on met à la porte les gens pour
des raisons qui sont purement
financières
on est là dans une logique absurde et
évidemment il faut le dénoncer
c'est grave également pour le territoire
tout le territoire de montigny saint
quentin en yvelines c'est un territoire
qui a fait le pari de l'intelligence qui
a fait le pari des métiers d'avenir café
le père par ida recherche café de
pareils et d'industrie de pointe et si
ça c'est menacer et bien nous voyons
bien que seul territoire qu'il est aussi
donc voilà il ya quelque chose qui est
très important aujourd'hui à défendre et
on parle religion à présent je vous le
disais en titre la fête religieuse de
l'aïd el kébir ça a débuté aujourd'hui
coup de projecteur sur cette première
journée nos équipes sont allées à la
rencontre des fidèles à montigny le
bretonneux et sur l'abattoir de trappes
un reportage de michael et demi d'euros
et patrick jacques de dixmude 1
l'aïd el kébir l'une des fêtes les plus
importantes de l'islam a débuté
aujourd'hui ce jeudi matin les musulmans
étaient appelés à venir prier à partir
de 8h à montigny le bretonneux plus de
200 fidèles se sont réunis au gymnase
roger rivière ce rendez vous l'imam a
notamment insisté sur la situation des
migrants
le message clé de cette allocution de
l'imam c'est en faveur pour déjà pour
sensibiliser la communauté à cette fête
il faut partager avec les nécessiteux
les pauvres il faut penser aux du mythe
démunis à ceux qui souffrent dans les
autres pays
donc c'est ça le message clé et c'est le
message et c'est les fondements de
l'islam de tolérance et de paix une fois
la prière terminée direction l'abattoir
mobile de trappes sur place les fidèles
viennent récupérer un mouton commander
sur internet
ici on peut observer le sacrifice rituel
de l'animal c'est une tradition qu'on a
grandi avec et c'est une tradition qu'on
a pris avec notre religion du picon et
eti du coup ça c'est important qu'on
assiste et en transmis à ça à nos
enfants le bouton est ensuite découpé
par des professionnels la carcasse
entière et de lait directement clients
quelques minutes après sa mort de fer
barbecue avec les enfants et on va
passer la journée on va pas la tête on
va le partager en trois tiers un tiers
c'est pour les nécessiteux un tiers pour
la famille ou ont partagé avec la
famille les amis et lin tiers pour la
petite famille qui est la nôtre
wallace et c'est l'esprit dans lequel
tout musulman doit vivre cette fête
c'est de grande fête l'aïd el kébir
durera jusqu'à ce samedi à trappes plus
de 1400 moutons ont été sacrifiés pour
ce cinquième pilier de l'islam on est un
mot de santé pour continuer le centre
hospitalier de versailles a annoncé la
création d'un fonds de dotation
le centre qui a vu son activité croître
ces dernières années aujourd'hui besoin
d'un soutien financier supplémentaire
afin de pourvoir à la modernisation des
équipements mais aussi au développement
de la recherche avec le soutien de la
ville l'inauguration de ce fonds aura
lieu tout le week-end
compter de vendredi au programme
conférences concerts et vente aux
enchères d'oeuvres d'art
un reportage des williams elle
d'anciennes prothèse reconverti en
oeuvre d'art si michel a pour habitude
de réaliser ses sculptures pour le
plaisir cette fois ci il le fait à
contribution de l'hôpital
c'est un peu comme une boucle ce petit
clin d'oeil qui part justement de l'est
fait que les pièces sont recyclés et que
l'argent de le bénéfice de cette vente
reviendra automatiquement de fonds de
dotation à fond de dotation pour le
centre hospitalier de versailles
l'hôpital lance un appel au mécénat pour
soutenir l'établissement conférences
concerts et vente aux enchères vont
ponctuer ce week-end de lancement pour
récolter des fonds
l'objectif de réduction des déficits des
comptes publics a amené le gouvernement
à demander aux établissements de santé
réduire leurs charges et cette réduction
de charges et s'est traduite pour le
moment par une diminution des tarifs
pour les hôpitaux une diminution
tarifaire qui représente une perte de 2
millions d'euros sur l'année 2015 pour
le fonds de dotation trois objectifs ont
été fixés
l'amélioration de conditions de vie des
patients le développement de la
recherche et la modernisation des
équipements ça va aussi bien d'une gamma
caméra en médecine nucléaire ou d'une
irm dont qui sont de très gros
équipements qui valent plusieurs
millions d'euros avec l'ouverture de
nouveaux services comme celui de la
médecine nucléaire inauguré il ya trois
mois mais aussi une forte augmentation
du recours aux services des urgences
la direction de l'hôpital s'est fixé
l'objectif de 200 mille euros de levée
de fonds annuelle des dons défiscalisés
hauteur de 60% pour les entreprises et
66 % pour les particuliers et la
ministre de la santé marisol touraine a
présenté ce jeudi son projet de plan de
financement de la sécurité sociale pour
2016 l'objectif premier de ce projet de
loi est de trouver 3,4 milliards
d'économies pour passer sous la barre
des 10 milliards de déficit en 2016 une
réforme surveillé par les professionnels
du secteur comme les pharmaciens en
france une officine ferme tous les deux
jours regardez ce reportage de rudy
hamel elodie moines 150 pharmaciens ont
fermé en 2014 et elle était déjà plus de
100 au 1er juillet 2015 avoir mis la clé
sous la porte
inquiet les pharmaciens attendait le
projet de plan de financement de la
sécurité sociale pour 2016 présenté ce
matin par la ministre de la santé qui
prévoit 1 milliard d'euros d'économie
sur les baisses de prix des médicaments
et le développement des génériques à
pharmaciens qui vous soit
voir on se rattrape sur les volumes pour
l'apparat la diététique et tout ça les
petites pharmacies en font très peu
c'est pour ça qu'ils sont touchés de
plein fouet
c'est très alarmant je suis dit surtout
pour les pharmacies moyennes et petites
et notamment en province
550 millions d'euros d'économies sont
prévues sur les baisses des prix qui
impacte surtout les petites officines
au programme également l'incitation au
recours aux génériques qui
représenterait 395 millions d'euros
d'économies nous on a une obligation car
la sécurité sociale nous dit pour
continuer à exercer il faut faire plus
de 80% de médicaments génériques sur les
médicaments qu'ils existent
l'objectif du gouvernement passait sous
la barre des 10 milliards d'euros de
déficit en 2016 pour les médicaments
génériques
une campagne de communication est prévue
pour le début de l'année prochaine et
devant la chambre de commerce et
d'industrie de versailles yvelines
organise la deuxième édition dès ce
mardi au campus de hec à jouy-en-josas
pour en parler avec moi patrick
bernaille membres du bureau de la
chambre de commerce et d'industrie de
versailles yvelines
alors le thème de demain c'est
l'économie circulaire et collaborative
pourquoi ce thème parce que c'est un des
thèmes que nous avons choisie sur
lesquels nous travaillons beaucoup
actuellement l'économie circulaire c'est
tout de même l'économie de tout ce qui
peut être recyclé
et il est évident qu'à te ment
l'économie française ne peut pas
continuer à travailler sur des
productions sans penser en même temps au
recyclage et des économique nous
pourrions faire sur le recyclage de
pneus tous nos produits à l'économie
salaires voilà ça vous l'avez ça
consiste en s'inspirant du
fonctionnement des écosystèmes naturels
à transformer les déchets en matières
premières utilisées pour la conception
des produits pour d'autres utilisations
ça concerne vraiment les entreprises
qu'il y en a peut-être qui ont du mal à
se projeter par rapport à ce thème si
bien sûr peut-être que les entreprises
ne connaissent pas tous ces intérêts
qu'il peut y avoir derrière dans les
entreprises que nous avons consultés et
avec lesquels nous travaillons depuis un
certain temps on s'est aperçu que leur
compte d'exploitation
c'est toujours améliorer dès l'instant
où elles se sont intéressés à un
recyclage vous demain il va y avoir des
ateliers vais avoir des conférences le
but
exactement c'est de vraiment donner un
peu des conseils aux entreprises sur
leur fonctionnement ou peut-être leur
donner des idées pour se lancer dans de
nouveaux c'est tout conseil puisqu'il
ira toute une partie après des
discussions entre entreprises entre
elles donc et des conseils et pia de la
recherche de savoir comment faire dans
chacun dans son métier et il n'y a pas
que les métiers de production
industrielle qui sont intéressés le
secteur tertiaire est aussi intéressé
par loïc l'homme vous avez des exemples
d'entreprises et viennoise qui sont
justement à l'enfance est économique oui
bien sûr un certain nombre dans les plus
grandes on peut parler par exemple de
renault renault qui s'est lancé quelques
uns sont des usines à flins qui est
double
tout le technocentre sur guyancourt
renault s'est lancé dans l'économie
circulaire et recycle énormément et
justement leur nom s'aperçoit
qu'aujourd'hui l'économie est derrière
est démontrée psa a fait exactement la
même chose aussi aujourd'hui
donc on s'imagine que pour des grosses
entreprises ballon on voit peut-être ce
qui a gagné en faisant très attention a
justement à ces économies là ne pas
faire attention à l'énergie que l'on
dépense mais pour des plus petites
entreprises je pense notamment à des
artisans
est ce que c'est c'est vallonné a valu à
voici bien sûr c'est bien sûr bien sûr
on a des petits artisans qui ou des
petites entreprises des pme des tpe qui
se sont intéressés ou qui s'intéressent
maintenant dans l'innovation de
l'économie circulaire et dégagent aussi
un certain nombre de profits on sait au
niveau de l'europe que l'économie
circulaire pourrait produire en gros 380
milliards d'euros ils 135e dollars
excusez moi et 135 mille emplois en
france alors entre 135 mille quatre cent
mille c'est énorme c'est vraiment mal à
l'économie circulaire collaborative
c'est une dynamique vous essayez vous
essayé d'impulser à la chambre de
communes tout à fait tout à fait
l'économie circulaire dynamique
collaborative est quelque chose que nous
voulons impulser et nous voulons aussi
impulser vraiment le dialogue entre les
grandes entreprises et les tpe et les
pme
on sait qu'aujourd'hui c'est par là de
développement économique tu auras
passait par rapport justement à la cci
télé un petit peu les grands événements
de cette année la rentrée s'il va se
passer pour nous en dire un peu plus oui
sauf que on en parlait il ya une
conférence de presse qu'il a donnée par
le président dans les jours qui viennent
mais oui nous avons d'autres d'autres
projets l'un des projets c
nobody 9 l'open innove qui est un projet
d'innovation pas seulement sont ceux
recyclables aussi sur son recyclage mais
sur l'ensemble des activités de
l'entreprise l'innovation pour nous est
un pôle extrêmement important et on va
développer beaucoup d'innovations sur le
département civile en économie
collaborative aussi on va développer un
site informatique a cité numérique pour
justement permettre aux entreprises de
pouvoir mieux qu'on se travailler entre
elles en coparticipation en caux équipe
où nous aurons les moyens les
possibilités d'arriver à développer de
véritables projets est ce qu'il ya une
problématique une dynamique qui se
dégage spécifiquement soit territoire
des civils cette année où ce cas vous
allez travailler plus précisément par
rapport à la région ile de france
oui je pense que vous pensez aux spots
puis sur le secteur de production de de
productivité je ne suis plus le terme
exact défaut territoire et tourisme et
tourisme ou là nous avons un point
extrêmement important
nous avons enlevé déjà un concours que
nous avons eues avec lui
ministère notre projet a été retenu
parmi une soixante dix projets douze
projets ont été retenus dont ceux de la
chambre de commerce de versailles
yvelines
et là nous allons développer le tourisme
sur toute la vallée de seine la vallée
de seine est un secteur touristique
extrêmement important qu'il n'existe qui
n'est pas vraiment exploité les yvelines
sont connus par le château de versailles
on vient de monde entier vélodrome un
petit peu maintenant bientôt par le golf
aussi scott sur vidal sur 50 arrivée
mais il n'y a pas que ça dans les
yvelines et ces deux événements majeurs
qui vont nous a indiqué qu'ils sont là
sont des événements qui vont permettre
aussi de faire parler de ce qui existe
dans les yvelines et qui permettrait aux
artisans commerçants et à tout le monde
d'avoir aussi un développement grâce au
tourisme que l'on pourrait développer
sur toute la vallée de seine justement
demain le rendez vous a lieu hec sociale
voilà une espèce de vitrine pour pour
vous que la cci vous pourrez faire
rayonner à chaud c'est une école de la
chambre de commerce
donc c'était des crèmes que nous avons
créée qui existe et qui est qui est une
propriété de la chambre de commerce il
est naturel qu'on utilise aussi ce
relais qui pendant une façon de dire
mais tout ça est important s'il va y
avoir aussi d'autres rendez-vous
peut-être hec pour attirer peut-être
d'autres entreprises qui ne souhaitent
pas tout de suite se tourner vers la
chambre de commerce et bien sûr bien sûr
on aura d'autres rendez vous au travers
de choses c'est bien sûr et demain par
exemple je sais pas s'il y avait un
atelier une conférence à ne pas rater
qui donnera peut-être aux entrepreneurs
ont envie de venir
toutes les conférences je n'ai pas
cibler une part être particulièrement
jeudi d'avoir quatre ateliers il va y
avoir une conférence plénière il va
d'activité puis après il y aura une part
d'un prêt midi du be to be aussi à faire
donc je pense que c'est la journée qui
est intéressante et chacun d'entre nous
doit regarder sur le programme ce qui va
intéresser le plus près de 300
entreprises donc à se rendre justement à
sur le site
oui sur les 3700 entreprises identifiées
sur l'économie circulaire dans le
département ce qui est déjà beaucoup
300 ont déjà répondu ce qui est un
succès je le rappelle demain la deuxième
édition de ce mardi 7 à jouy en josas
jouy en josas pardon sur le campus de
hec
plus d'informations sur le site de la
chambre de commerce et d'industrie de
versailles www.cc 78 tirs et des point
fr et nous continuons avec un autre mode
économie nous vous en avions parlé
l'année dernière le site de rencontres
versaillais by which vient d'être élue
lauréat 2015 de réseau entreprendre
accompagnateurs de projets grâce à cette
nomination le site beach va point fr va
bénéficier pendant les trois prochaines
années d'un accompagnement et obtient un
prêt d'honneur de 30000 euros
by which point fr compte aujourd'hui
plus de 12000 célibataires inscrits et
on passe maintenant au sport avec un mot
de boxe le boxing club de la verrière
meilleur club français de boxe éducative
vit une rentrée compliquée depuis début
septembre l'équipe doit s'entraîner dans
une salle provisoire la faute à un
retard pris dans le chantier de
rénovation du gymnase du bois de l'étang
pour les dirigeants locaux sont
inadaptés à la pratique de ce sport et
cela fait un petit peu polémique
le nombre d'adhérents a également
diminué à cause justement de ce retard
de livraison on écoute hassan aourid le
directeur sportif du club
il était au micro d' elodie moines on
atteint difficilement les 50 alors
j'en veux dire la même période on était
déjà 70 80 alors ça vous parle peut-être
pas mais c'est énorme quand j'ai des
gens qui viennent qui sont ce qu'ils
sont qui sont pas encore inscrits qui ne
viennent pas parce qu'il ya pas de
douche
j'en ai d'autres qui ne viennent pas
parce qu'il ya de la poussière alors on
peut alors il est clair et net que je
demande pas la ville de tout arranger
c'est pas c'est pas possible ça on en a
conscience mais néanmoins on aimerait
que ça passe dans l'autre sens que ça ça
que ce soit pas de nous qui réclamions
qu'elles soient eux qui se met un petit
peu à la place des pratiquants des
adhérents parents et enfants et
maintenant comme chaque semaine vous
avez l'habitude de ce rendez vous c'est
maintenant l'heure de votre chronique
sport avec les rangs du bo les
rendez-vous du week-end à ne pas monter
présenté par notre forum
alors le week-end sera très sportif dans
les yvelines je suppose que vous êtres
vidéo je suis ravi que oui il y aura
notamment du football avec la coupe de
france il y aura également de la course
à pied avec paris versailles mais
également du basket l'équipe de trappes
se déplace sur le terrain de
marly-le-roi ce samedi à 20h pour le
compte de la nationale 3 pour nous
parler de ce match nous recevrons joey
casseus le pivot de trappes qui mesure
deux mètres 11 c'est sa fin c'est ça
alors expliquez nous un petit peu cette
reprise où vous allez commencer ce
championnat comme en bas là on se
déplace comme vous l'avez dit à
marly-le-roi ce week-end et on a fait
une bonne préparation jusqu'à maintenant
et le coach met en place le jeu et
uniquement
et là on y voit très motivés
d'instruction pour le prochain match et
ce premier match
vous sentez comment ce premier match -
grâce à ses personnels motivés motivés
je pense que normalement devrait en
aucun cas négliger ce père et ce qui est
déjà une cohésion d'équipé vous pariez
goût d'entraînement est-ce que vous
entraîner à peu près depuis fin août
début septembre
tous ensemble est-ce qu'il ya déjà une
cohésion à des équipes bien sûr des gens
s'entraînent faut savoir qu'on
s'entraîne tous les jours donc bon même
si c'est un niveau d'un signal on fait
tous les efforts pour pour se préparer
au mieux et le coach est très
pointilleuse sur sa mise en place
donc moi personnellement je suis très à
l'aise dans l'effectif et on va faire
quelque chose de bien cette saison et ça
se met en place tout doucement comme
vous l'avez dit depuis des doutes
le coach mais ça fait la fidi là depuis
environ trois ans est-ce que son message
passe toujours auprès des joueurs ben
vous savez sont celles avec attention la
vue plus trois ans et que pour l'enfant
se portent bien après et c'est très bien
qu'il ya un certain temps pour ça se met
en place et
là tout doucement on comprend un petit
peu ce qui se passe et le recrutement de
cette année va-t-il vous permettre de
réussir à monter en nationale 2 vous
avez d'ailleurs été recrutés c'est à
l'afp moi je fais partie de ce
recrutement on a recruté un bonheur
aussi
qu'ils s'appellent à briguer qui annonce
un professionnel en vue d'une fin de
carrière à trappes
donc on a ils ont misé en fait sur
beaucoup de gens d'expérience cette
année et on la gagne en expérience et ça
a gagné en expérience a gagné en taille
aussi avec moi et donc voilà maintenant
vous répondre sincèrement on va attendre
les premiers matches
le classement au niveau du tiers du
championnat et après je pourrais vous
dire c'est on est vraiment ici dans dans
le haut du tableau on va revenir au
match contre marie leroy quelles sont
les recettes pour organiser ce match il
va vous avez déjà c'est un match qu'on
va jouer à l'extérieur donc en jeu à
l'extérieur on parle pas forcément
favoris même si on est supérieur à
l'adversaire les clés ça va être
l'agressivité défensive parce que les
trappes a toujours eu un petit peu de
mal à l'extérieur sur les dernières
saisons
parcourant les allées entre les cinq ans
et à l'extérieur il faut être très
rigoureux sur l'agressivité défensive ne
pas laisser l'adversaire être en
confiance nous pas laisser le trempe là
son jeu et le montrer aussi une comment
dire une présence physique
à partir de là vous pouvez déjà mettre
le doute d'un jeu de l'adversaire c'est
les clés en main à l'extérieur ne pas
laisser l'équipe qui reçoit mettre son
jeu en place
donc après c'est bien de le dire mais
bon on va vous falloir le faire et le
fait que ce soit un derby ça va
peut-être changer quelque chose
je sais pas par exemple les rebonds doit
être plus âpre le public sera peut-être
un peu plus chaud bah je pense que wayne
le feuilleton une ambiance et un peu
chaude puisque ces deux équipes qui sont
très proches au niveau de la distance et
nous déjà le déplacement va être court
donc on fera tout frais pour le mac
c'est parfait et donc votre pronostic
sur ce match vu que toi un peu près 20
points d'écart par 10 points il ya un an
pronostic victoire 12-6
ça les a tout ce qu'il nous faut merci à
vous d'être passé sur ce plateau et bon
courage pour ce premier match on vous
souhaite un bon courage il y aura
également du football mickaël avec la
france toujours avec quatrième tour ce
week-end la wii flora ne je vois que je
sais que vous êtes une passionnée de
foot show passionnés trappe donc équipe
de promotion d'honneur reçoit versailles
équipe de dh pour ce 4e tour de la coupe
de france pour un derby sulfureux les
trappistes auront à coeur de réaliser un
gros match pour se qualifier pour ce 5e
tour
le match s'annonce tout de même
compliquée trois divisions séparent les
deux clubs pour combler cet écart trappe
compte s'appuie sur son public pour
faire la différence dans ce match
la rencontre est programmée ce dimanche
à 14h30 dans l'antre du stade gilbert
gensac toujours en coupe de france se
mord pas qui évolue en division
d'excellence a hérité du statut du petit
poucet du département en sortant au tour
précédent gennevilliers ce dimanche
après-midi les mort d'asia recevront
l'équipe de torcy au stade du bout du
clos dimanche à 14h30 une équipe qui
évolue deux divisions au dessus des
yvelinois qu'il est réputé pour sa
formation
un certain paul pogba aujourd'hui
joueurs de l'équipe de france est
d'ailleurs passé par torcy il ya une
dizaine d'années l'expo va donc être
compliqué mais tout est possible en
coupe de france il reste dix matches à
gagner pour les mort passe bien pour
aller au stade de france selon termina
cette chronique par la course à pied
effectivement florane la course à pied
paris versailles programmé ce dimanche
puis de 25 mille coureurs prendront le
départ de ses 16 km les sportifs
s'élanceront par vagues à partir de 10h
depuis la tour eiffel
ils passeront ensuite par la redoutable
côte des gars de meudon vie reflet avant
de terminer leur périple sur l'avenue de
paris de versailles en face du château
un parcours plutôt facile pour un bon
coureur mais qui risque d'être une
torture pour les novices les premiers
devraient arriver aux alentours de 10h45
à versailles je sais que michael vous
avez l'habitude de cours et alors la
difficulté pour ceux qui nous regardent
avec ils vont justement s'atteler à sept
courses de la côte des gardes justement
paris vers taille quel point il faut
faire attention surtout fait attention
aux montées la montée très très
compliqué de kilomètres de montée il
faut avoir notamment de bons mollets de
bon il est très bien aimé vous avez
entendu les conseils de michaël nickel
on vous retrouvera lundi prochain à
18h30 dans le set hui sport pour un
débrief complète ses rendez vous et nous
restons sur le sport pour refermer cette
édition un événement vient de rentrer
dans l'histoire arunas soumaré licenciés
ou sdcl senteurs de remords pas à
remporter
samedi dernier le tout premier gala de
mma organisé en france au cirque d'hiver
à paris
alors le hamas sont les arts martiaux
mixtes appelé aussi free fight
le mort patient s'est facilement imposée
dans ce combat face à christophe de
cordes au troisième round devant plus de
600 spectateurs ce gala était la
première compétition officielle de mma
programmé dans l'hexagone
jusqu'ici les autorités françaises
interdisait la pratique de cette
discipline en compétition c'est la fin
maintenant de cette édition je vous
remercie de nous avoir suivis demain
vous retrouvez wilfried richy pour votre
journal quant à moi je retrouvais lundi
à 18 heures pour une nouvelle édition de
ce journal en direct je vous souhaite un
très bon week-end et une très bonne
soirée sur tv fil 78